[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui à un conflit d'une
brutalité extrême mais il oppose le
gouvernement fédéral éthiopien et un
groupe rebelle de l'ethnie tigre est
leur confrontation a déjà provoqué une
véritable catastrophe humanitaire dans
le pays et fait craindre la montée de
nouvelles tensions dans la région quel
est donc l'état des lieux dans ce
conflit plus d'un an après son
éclatement le 7 octobre l'armée
éthiopienne annonce une offensive sur
les positions des rebelles tigréens ceci
appuyé par de nombreux autres groupes
insurgés se lance dans la contre attaque
plusieurs villes stratégiques passe de
main en main la situation humanitaire se
détériore un certain nombre d'acteurs
politiques se trouvent impliqués dans ce
conflit différentes sources dénonce les
livraisons d'armes addis abeba par les
émirats arabes unis et la turquie
l'ethiopie quand elle accuse le soudan
de soutenir et d'entraîner les rebelles
l'union africaine en dos activement le
rôle de médiateur dans ce conflit
l'envoyé spécial de l'organisation
visite en novembre l'ethiopie et
s'entretient avec les représentants des
rebelles le dialogue avance à pas timide
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur le rapport de force actuel
dans ce conflit d'une violence inédite
c'est le blitz d'abord il ya le
gouvernement fédéral éthiopien dirigé
par le premier ministre habib ahmed son
armée compte entre 140 milles et 160
mille soldats selon les différentes
estimations avions de combat chars
hélicoptères systèmes de défense
aérienne la supériorité technologique
est certes du côté des forces fédérales
face à elle le front populaire de
libération du petit gris qui dirige de
fait la région éthiopienne du tigre et
mes écrits est perçu comme organisation
terroriste par le gouvernement
différentes sources suppose qu'ils
comptent entre 100000 et 250 mille
combattants qui contrôle actuellement la
majeure partie de la région du tigré
chacun de ces deux antagonistes
bénéficie du soutien de groupes armés
locaux ainsi l'armée fédérale est
soutenue par les milices amara quant aux
rebelles ils bénéficient de l'aide de
l'armée de libération oromo une autre
organisation rebelle et de plusieurs
autres groupes armés
plus d'un an après le début du conflit
l'armée fédérale et les rebelles
tigréens se livrent une bataille sans
merci pour le contrôle de certaines
villes stratégiques plusieurs groupes
armés s'y mêlent certains prennent le
parti de la rébellion mais l'armée
fédérale s'assure du soutien de l'ethnie
aymara certaines sources parlent de
livraison d'armes à l'ethiopie par les
émirats arabes unis et la turquie de son
côté addis abeba accuse le soudan
d'entraîner les rebelles si gré 1 en
effet les relations entre les deux pays
voisins continuent à se dégrader en
raison notamment du barrage éthiopien
considéré comme une menace par khartoum
dans ce contexte il n'est pas étonnant
que la proposition de médiation que le
soudan a avancé pour le conflit en
ethiopie et été rejetées par addis abeba
en revanche la médiation piloté par
l'union africaine fait bouger les lignes
alors comment habib ahmed prix nobel de
la paix en 2019 mène-t-il aujourd'hui
une vaste opération militaire contre les
rebelles tigréens pourquoi toutes les
tentatives d'engager le processus de
paix n'ont elles pas abouti jusqu'ici
enfin quelles sont les racines du
conflit en cours pour répondre à toutes
ces questions nous rejoignons patrick
ferrasse docteur en géopolitique
président de l'association stratégie
africaine monsieur ferrasse bonjour
bonjour tout d'abord le début du mandat
dhabi art med était certes prometteur
avec le prix nobel de la paix qu'il vait
été attribués comment en est il arrivé à
un conflit dans son propre pays encore
bien m prend le pouvoir en 2018 il le
fait grâce à une alliance entre les
oromos sa région d'origine et les
amharas en contrant les tigres et al ce
qu'on appelle le tipi est la femme au
sein d'une coalition que l'on appelle le
prdf qui comprend principalement une
branche lamarre a une qui gréhaigne une
des papys du sud et new roman il fait
donc déjà de mécontents ce que la
communauté internationale n'a pas vu ou
voulu voir dans l'accord de paix de 2018
et donc de l'attribution de ce prix
nobel de la paix c'est l alliance entre
les deux pires ennemis des tigres et un
celi habib ahmed qui vient avec une soif
de revanche il était militaire il est
exclu de l'armée il a commencé sa
carrière politique et issaias afeworki
le président érythréen qui se souvient
de la déroute militaire de 1998 2000
face à larvik soutiennent dirigé
commandé par les tigres donc d'accord de
paix il fallait simplement relire les
tigres et un rendront quelques
kilomètres carrés de territoire aux
séries train ce que mêlés zenawi
l'ancien premier ministre ne voulait pas
y avait combattu depuis 2002 et se
lacérer l'alliance militaire entre les
deux pays pour réduire dans le futur les
velléités des tigres et c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé la comédie est un
seul n'a rien vu trop contente de croire
que nouveaux leaders africains étaient
nés ou pouvant voir aujourd'hui nous
mêmes cette prod analyse l'attribution
du nobel démontre le manque de maturité
le manque de recul de ce qu'on appelle
la communauté internationale et pourquoi
selon vous est il si difficile et
aujourd'hui pour les forces
gouvernementales de reprendre le
contrôle sur la région rebelle
l'histoire de la chute 2010 ou en 1991
aurait dû éclairer habib ahmed sur la
capacité de les ans et de résistance du
petit grain qui avait lutté pendant 17
ans contre mengestu rampant sans
détruire les leaders du tigré r&d
tigréens si on veut dire par l'invasion
du tigré par l'armée tioukine pas
l'armée érythréenne par les mini safar
et av ait amara le premier ministre a
fait une erreur stratégique parce qu'il
n'a pas su voir la ville est là la force
des forces tigréenne et après 14 mois il
est au même point que le 3 4 novembre
2020 excepté que la majeure partie des
infrastructures du territoire petits
grains a été détruite et les
bombardements par drones continue ce que
ce qui est important de noter et c'est
que l'armée éthiopienne malgré l'apport
des éléments que j'ai incité les ports
étrangers a reculé entre juin et
novembre 2000 21 jusqu'à se retrouver à
moins de 200 dur et d'addis abeba la
capitale
une fois de plus sans l'aide étrangère
notamment l'achat massif d'armements et
l'aide des puissances secteurs comme la
turquie ou les émirats arabes unis les
tigres 1 serait aujourd'hui abeba le
couperet n'est pas passé très loin de la
tête du premier ministre ce qui explique
peut-être le fait qu'il ait quitté addis
abeba assez précipitamment au mois de
décembre 2021 c'est sûrement pas pour
commander les troupes castres carrière
était assez courte au niveau militaire
mais c'était sûrement peut-être par la
peur d'être pris au piège par les forces
tigre et elle est aujourd'hui la région
tigre nl et sanctuary zay par ses
propres tigréens qui sont sous ciel et
france précités et notamment érythréenne
et elle reste a priori hors de portée de
la gamme est acceptée par les attaques
aériennes y at il à un risque
aujourd'hui que ce conflit dégénère en
une guerre civile à grande échelle c'est
dire si vie elle est déjà là plusieurs
mouvements d'opposition habib ahmed sont
réunis au sein d'une coalition redon le
tibet est fait un peu le dire ce que
l'on peut dire ce qui montre qu'un le
mécontentement actuel et les fragilités
de cet état les combats se sont déroulés
il faut pas l'oublier en région il a
aimé aussi en région amara gars qui fait
la guerre civile elle est déjà là et
sont les populations de ces trois
régions qui sont premières loges du
conflit et de sa reprise éventuelle
quant à la faction de l'armée de
libération oromo qui est aussi membre de
cette coalition contre habib ahmed elle
continue sa lutte en région romo
fragilisé sa sécurité du pays donc à ce
jour vous voyez mais rien n'est résolu
et croire qu'un dialogue de
réconciliation nationale peut déboucher
sur l'été du pays et la fin des
hostilités est une erreur et un simple
gain de temps avec un signal pour le
comité international et lui faire croire
que les affaires sont en train d'être
réglés en passe d'être réglé le dialogue
ne sera utile que lorsque le conflit
majeur au tigre sera résolu ou sur la
bonne voie vers un cessez le feu ou un
dialogue entre a bien mais dd brayonne
de patron du ps mais au vu des attaques
et rien de ces derniers jours et malgré
la libération de quelques détenus
politiques la volonté dhabi à même de
mettre au pas la région qu'il a il reste
la même et la paire need you qui demeure
peu problable avec ses conséquences
politiques et économiques dans le pays
mais aussi à l'extérieur merci beaucoup
monsieur ferrasse nous allons poursuivre
notre analyse tout de suite mais nous
vous retrouverons à la fin de cette
émission pour plus de détails sur ce
thème évidemment merci encore dans le
conflit aux tigres et les lignes de
front évolue de jour en jour le 21
décembre l'armée éthiopienne reprend le
contrôle de la libye la ville du nord de
l'ethiopie qui abrite un site classé au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco c'est la
troisième fois en un mois que cette
ville passe de main en main tantôt elle
est contrôlée par le gouvernement tantôt
par les rebelles la bataille pour la
libye la néo qu'un des épisodes de cette
nouvelle escalade qui commence le 7
octobre avec l'annoncé de l'offensive
par le gouvernement les positions des
rebelles sont bombardés puis une vaste
opération sur le terrain est lancé
l'objectif étant de reprendre le
contrôle du centre administratif de
l'état du tigré mekele en s'avançant sur
les axes routiers à leur tour les
rebelles tigréens se lance dans une
contre-offensive le 27 octobre ils
réussissent à s'emparer des villes de
taissy et de combo jazz situé sur une
autoroute reliant la capitale au nord du
pays et à djibouti la victoire s'avère
pourtant fragile en décembre les forces
gouvernementales chasse les rebelles de
ces zones pourtant les rebelles
d'aujourd'hui sont en grande partie les
représentants du pouvoir dit hier la
principale force rebelle qui se pose
aujourd'hui au gouvernement front
populaire de libération du tigre est
dominée autrefois la vie politique du
pays les représentants du peuple
tigréens une minorité représentant 6% de
la population détenez quasi tous les
postes clés du pays et ce jusqu'à
l'arrivée au pouvoir d'abhisit à remède
en 2018 figure de compromis il
promettait une réconciliation nationale
après une vague de manifestations
antigouvernementales
une fois au pouvoir le nouveau premier
ministre entame une série de réformes et
cartes de nombreux dirigeants tigréens
du pouvoir son parti de la prospérité
qu'ils créent en 2019 intègre les
principales forces politiques du pays
sauf une le front populaire de
libération du tigre et la tension
déborde en 2020 cette année là le pays
aurait dû tenir des élections générales
mais elles ont été reportées par le
gouvernement d'abyei achmed en raison du
coc vide or les autorités du tigre et
décident néanmoins d'organiser le
scrutin au niveau régional malgré
l'interdiction du pouvoir central
estimant ce scrutin illégitime
le parlement fédéral dissous le
gouvernement du tigré et réduit le
financement de la région une déclaration
de guerre selon les responsables
tigréens dans la nuit du 3 novembre 2020
les forces du front populaire de
libération du tigré attaque deux bases
de l'armée fédérale les forces
gouvernementales éthiopienne réplique la
presse locale ainsi que de nombreuses
éditions internationales évoque
aujourd'hui le risque de désintégration
du pays car ce conflit s'étend à
d'autres régions et comprend un nombre
d'acteurs de plus en plus nombreux en
août dernier le front populaire de
libération du tigre et forgent une
alliance avec l'armée de libération
oromo l'autre force de guérilla qui se
bat pour l'autonomie de la région
d'oromia la plus vaste et la plus
peuplée des tubes plusieurs opérations
conjointes sont menées par la suite le 5
novembre cet autre groupe rebelle
rejoigne l'alliance qui s'appelle
désormais le front uni des forces
fédéralistes et confédéraliste
éthiopienne quant au gouvernement
central est là aussi un appui de taille
les milices amara qui se bat ardemment
contre le front populaire de libération
du tigre est depuis le début de la
guerre représentants la deuxième ethnie
de l'ethiopie ces combattants souhaite
avant tout reprendre le contrôle sur les
territoires à l'ouest et au sud du tigre
est rattachée autrefois à la région
d'amhara
pratiquement tous les acteurs de ce
conflit sont accusés par le nu de graves
abus et violations des droits de l'homme
afin de freiner cette spirale de
violence l'onu appelle au cessez le feu
sans conditions préalables le
gouvernement n'avance qu'une seule
condition pour le début du dialogue avec
le front populaire de libération du
tigre est le désarmement total quant aux
rebelles ils ont plusieurs exigences
dont le retrait des forces
pro-gouvernementales du tigre et la
reconnaissance des élections régionales
une large autonomie enfin une enquête
internationale sur les violations des
droits de l'homme par le gouvernement si
ces conditions ne sont pas remplies le
front populaire de libération du tigre
et compte aller jusqu'au bout pour
renverser ab ahmed et former un
gouvernement de transition et pendant
que les combats continuent à faire rage
dans le pays la situation humanitaire se
dégrade à une vitesse alarmante plus de
9,4 millions de personnes vivant dans le
nord du pays font face à une grave
insécurité alimentaire selon l'onu la
population du tigre est la plus touchée
90% des habitants et ont besoin d'une
aide humanitaire
le nombre de déplacés monte en flèche
ils sont aujourd'hui deux millions à
avoir quitté leur maison pour fuir les
violences l'accès à l'électricité aux
services de santé reste un luxe rare
pour la population du nord du pays une
situation qui se complexifie avec
l'accès difficile de l'onu dans la
région concernée la seule route par
laquelle ce fait la livraison de l'aide
humanitaire est l'objet d'un contrôle
renforcé de la part des autorités
régionales et fédérales sur fond d'une
situation humanitaire qui se détériore
le gouvernement éthiopien entreprend une
mesure inédite il expulse en septembre
dernier sept membres de l'onu chargé
principalement d'affaires humanitaire
addis abeba les accusent de partialité
et de manipulation d'informations le
secrétaire général de l''onu ne mâche
pas ses mots j'ai été choqué par
l'information selon laquelle le
gouvernement éthiopien a déclaré persona
non grata cette responsable des nations
unies y compris de hauts responsables
humanitaires des nations unies alors
comment les différents acteurs étrangers
poursuivent-t-ils leur intérêt dans ce
conflit en cours quelles sont les causes
de cette confrontation quels sont les
états qui s'en posent en tant que
médiateur la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
les violents affrontements ne font que
s'intensifier ces derniers temps en
ethiopie le nu insiste pourtant il n'y a
pas de solution militaire à ce bras de
fer entre le gouvernement et les
rebelles quel pourrait être le compromis
diplomatique
compte tenu du contexte historique
complexe de ce conflit l'ethiopie est
une mosaïque de plus de 80 ethnie dont
les principales sont les oromos et les
amharas et plus minoritaires les tigres
est un lait somalie et les afars c'est
également un état multi séculaire qui
n'a connu qu'une très brève période sous
domination italienne a par l'erythrée
qui l a été colonisée pendant environ 50
ans juste avant la seconde guerre
mondiale après la guerre l'ethiopie
cherche à reprendre le contrôle de
l'erythrée dont le statut reste
incertain et obtient des nations unies
en 1952 que l'erythrée lui soient
fédérées en 1962 l'ethiopie dissout la
fédération ce qui entraîne la formation
de mouvements de résistance armée
érythréens le début des années 1970 voit
une montée du mécontentement de la
population en ethiopie liées aux
inégalités sociales et à plusieurs
famine en 1974 la monarchie renversée et
un comité militaire prend le pouvoir
instaurant un régime socialiste dirigé
par le colonel mengistu plusieurs
mouvements de rébellion armée se forme
alors notamment aux tigres et avec le
front populaire de libération du tigré
fpl t outre les mouvements déjà
existants en erythrée dans le front
populaire de libération de l'erythrée à
partir de 1989 les deux mouvements
salies et avec la fin de l'urss et du
soutien soviétique le régime du colonel
mengistu est renversé en 1991 mélès
zenawi chef du fplp et président du
front démocratique révolutionnaire du
peuple éthiopien où fdr pe qui rassemble
les mouvements de rébellion devient
président d'un gouvernement de
transition en 1991 quant à l'erythrée
elle devient indépendante en 1993 après
un référendum d'autodétermination sous
le contrôle de l'onu l'ethiopie adopte
une nouvelle constitution en 1994 sur le
principe d'un fédéralisme ethnique le
fdr pe remporte les élections
législatives de 1995 ainsi que les
suivantes mélès zenawi devient premier
ministre les relations vont vite se
tendre entre l'ethiopie et l'erythrée
tout d'abord pour des raisons
économiques puis sur la question des
frontières en 1998 l'erythrée attaque la
région du bade mais dans le tigré
éthiopien déclenchant la guerre ce
conflit meurtrier ne se termine qu'en
2000 après une offensive éthiopienne et
la signature d'un accord de paix à alger
sous l'égide de l'organisation de
l'unité africaine
cependant l'ethiopie refuse les
conclusions de la commission chargée de
la démarcation de la frontière et les
deux pays reste dans une situation de
conflits gelés sous l'autorité de mêlés
zenawi l'ethiopie se lance dans de
grands projets de développement
notamment en infrastructures et à partir
des années 2000 le pays connaît une
forte croissance économique
cependant l'hégémonie du fdr pe et celle
du fplp en son sein sont de plus en plus
remise en cause à la mort 2 et la wii en
2012 un sudiste hailé mariam d allen lui
succède grâce à son omniprésence dans
les structures locales le fdr pee
remporté la quasi totalité des sièges
lors des élections de 2015 la même année
un mouvement de protestation éclatant
région oromo l'ethnie majoritaire en
ethiopie qui se sont de plus en plus
marginalisés sévèrement réprimée
mouvement s'étend à d'autres régions
dont celle des amarats d allen fini par
démissionner en février 2018 son
successeur à ben yahmed de père oromo et
de mer un marin était lui un mois et
demi plus tard à la tête du fdr pe est
nommé premier ministre
dès l'été 2010 8 ha ben yahmed et le
président érythréen issaias afeworki met
fin à l'état de guerre entre les deux
pays et rétablir les relations
diplomatiques
critique envers le fédéralisme ethnique
habib ahmed entreprend très vite de
contrer l'influencé du fdlt en décembre
2019 il décide là des solutions du fdr
pe et la création d'un nouveau parti le
parti de la prospérité en fusionnant les
quatre partis constituant le fdr pe et
en intégrant plusieurs autres le fplp
refuse la fusion et passe dans
l'opposition
lorsque habib ahmed reporte les
élections législatives prévues en 2020
en raison de la crise sanitaire le fplp
maintien leur organisation dans la
province du tigré en septembre en
novembre 2020 à bien mettre déclenché
une opération militaire contre les
autorités du tigre et qu'il accuse
d'avoir attaqué deux bases militaires
fidèles au gouvernement dans la région
ce conflit complexe dé bor dée frontière
éthiopienne une multitude d'acteurs
internationaux sont impliqués plus ou
moins directement dans les hostilités
par exemple l'erythrée voisine récemment
réconcilié avec l'ethiopie après des
dizaines d'années de style it et depuis
le début du conflit en novembre 2020 à
smara s'impliquent du côté des forces
gouvernementales éthiopienne et envoie
ses troupes dans le tigré pour assurer
la sécurité aux frontières les rebelles
tigréens répondent à cette opération par
des tirs de roquettes sur l'erythrée
l'implication d'asmara a joué un rôle
important en novembre 2020 dans la chute
rapide du tigre est aux mains des forces
gouvernementales pourtant l'erythrée
réfuté sa présence sur place jusqu'en
avril 2021 et au moment où ses troupes
sont mises en cause dans les violences
contre les civils par le nu et
l'erythrée annonce son retrait qui
s'achève vers l'été 2021
l'erythrée l'ethiopie ont pris la
décision commune d'entamer le retrait
des troupes érythréennes du tigre et
pourtant les accusations onusienne lui
valent des sanctions américaines
imposées en novembre dernier elle vise
le parti du président et l'armée
érythréenne cependant l'erythrée n'est
pas la seule à appuyer militairement
addis abeba selon la presse l'ethiopie
aurait aussi profité de l'appui des
émirats arabes unis comme le rapporte le
new york times au début de la guerre en
2020 abou dhabi a entraîné les troupes
éthiopiennes et a soutenu ses opérations
en lançant des raids sur les positions
des rebelles et s'est appuyé aurait
continué depuis d'après une enquête d'al
jazeera les émirats ont ouvert un pont
aérien pour fournir du matériel
militaire à l'ethiopie entre septembre
et novembre dernier sur fond
d'intensification des combats sur le
terrain en cause de cet appui la
position stratégique de l'ethiopie dans
la corne de l'afrique et son immense
potentiel économique qui intéresse les
émirats les tupi pourrait aussi
bénéficier de possibles ventes de drones
turc c'est ce que rapporte reuters en
octobre l'information est ensuite
confirmée par the guardian et le new
york times selon ce dernier pourtant
ankara aurait suspendu les exportations
vers l'ethiopie sous pression
internationale officiellement ni la
turquie ni l'ethiopie ne confirme ces
informations elles ont pour consigne en
août dernier un accord de coopération
militaire et en 2021 les exportations
militaires turques vers les cieux ppi
ont augmenté de plus de 400 fois par
rapport à 2020 et quid des rebelles du
tigré bénéficie-t-il d'un soutien
extérieur selon addis abeba ce serait
bien le cas des forces extérieures sont
engagés dans une guerre par procuration
contre l'ethiopie en soutenant les
rebelles du front populaire de
libération du tigre et nous avons des
preuves crédibles du soutien par
satellite du soutien en armement parmi
ces forces extérieures l'ethiopie pointe
le plus souvent du doigt le soudan
depuis le mois d'août addis abeba
accusent khartoum d'appuyer
entraîner les rebelles sur son
territoire y côtoie la région du tigré
pourquoi ce soutien est bien le soudan a
son propre conflit frontalier avec
l'ethiopie tout près du tigre et la
région d'alpha chaque à la dispute
autour de celle-ci se réchauffe pendant
la guerre du tigré et des altercations à
la frontière se multiplient de plus les
tensions persistent toujours entre les
deux pays au sujet du barrage de la
renaissance selon le soudan ce méga
projet éthiopien risque de le priver
d'eau sur fond de ces griefs multiples
le soudan propose néanmoins en août sa
médiation dans le conflit du tigre est
sans surprise l'offre est rejetée par
l'ethiopie la relation avec le soudan en
ce moment est un peu délicate car le
niveau de confiance s'est érodée surtout
avec l'incursion de l'armée soudanaise
sur le territoire éthiopien et la
confiance est la base de toute
négociation aux médiations donc ce point
doit être résolu avant de considérer le
soudain comme un parti crédible l'effort
de médiation lancée par l'union
africaine semble plus prometteur après
neuf mois de refus de ces efforts
l'union africaine parvient en août à
entamer enfin une médiation grâce à la
nomination de luz aygün obasandjo comme
son envoyé spécial le diplomate est bien
reçue à addis abeba et parvient à
surmonter le scepticisme des rebelles en
novembre ils visitent le pays et
rencontre le gouvernement puis les
tigres est une avancée timide qui se
heurte pourtant à un mur car aucune des
deux parties ne veut accepter les
conditions de l'autre et ce malgré une
multitude d'initiatives pour les pousser
vers la paix parmi les acteurs les plus
notables le kenya et les états unis qui
multiplie des visites en ethiopie et les
appels au cessez le feu la turquie elle
propose aussi sa médiation ces efforts
ont-ils une chance d'aboutir pour y voir
plus clair nous revenons vers patrick
ferrasse docteur en géopolitique
président de l'association stratégie
africaine monsieur ferrasse parlons
maintenant de l'aspect géopolitique de
ce conflit le barrage de la renaissance
attire le mécontentement du soudan et de
l'egypte ces derniers peuvent-ils
utiliser la crise éthiopienne pour en
tirer
des avantages en direct le soudan et
l'egypte ne sont pas datées de la même
façon par le barrage leur naissance
l'impact le plus important est d'intérêt
national comme l'a rappelé le président
si si il est en egypte le nil bleu qui
fournit 90% de l'eau utile aux égyptiens
vient du lac tana en ethiopie et c'est
donc vital pour l'ethiopie pour l'egypte
pardon le soudan pourrait être touchée
au niveau de l'agriculture de son
inculture mais ce n'est pas une cause
d'intérêt national voit donc il ya deux
objectifs complètement différent ce qui
est un peu brusque et les relations
entre les trois états c'est la faible
capacité des éthiopiens à vouloir
coopérer et cela s'est traduit par les
deux faces de remplissage de ce barrage
à l'été 2020 et 2021 pour l'ethiopie
c'est aussi un problème d'intérêt
national pour sa population son économie
et les ventes futures à l'étranger
d'électricité produite et donc sinon
négocia donc l'avenir est quand même à
la coopération au dialogue ce qui sera
difficile quand on connaît la situation
géopolitique des trois états
il n'y a pas de risque à mon avis de
conflit pour pour ma part mais ces
discussions devraient baisser en
intensité et déboucher sur une meilleure
compréhension des uns et des autres
voilà c'est un problème typiquement
africains qui ne doit pas être manipulés
ou instrumentalisés par des puissances
extérieures
malheureusement l'union africaine est
encore une fois la grande absente des
rendez vous importants ce qu'on peut
dire au delà cette crise éthiopienne
c'est qu'un impact aussi le soudan dans
un autre dans une autre perspective
c'est la nécessité de délimiter la
frontière entre le soudan et la partie
ouest si l'on peut dire de l'ethiopie
donc dans ce que l'on appelle le
triangle de fâches haga et qui est aussi
frontalier avec tigran donc cette cette
portion du territoire qu'on appelle le
walk est qu'ils étaient envahis par les
amharas dès le début du mois de novembre
2020 et qu'il veut le récupérer parce
qu'ils estiment qu'on leur a volé en
1991 sept heures portion territoire
extrêmement importante parce qu'elle
pourrait donner une espèce de porte de
sortie aux tigres et un par le soudan
puisque vous savez qu'aujourd'hui sont
bloqués par le sud l'armée éthiopienne
si l'on peut dire et par le nord leurs
mérites réels donc si pour la raison
pour laquelle il combats ont lieu
aujourd'hui dans cette portion de
territoire la frontière du soudan allait
soudan y at-il aujourd'hui en danger que
ce conflit déborde dans toute la région
déjà instable ans comme vous le
mentionnez la région elle est très
instable
et là pas besoin de ce conflit pour être
plus instable se stabiliser à revanche
ce qui est important c'est de voir que
l'accord de la bia met des le 2018 avec
la somalie l'erythrée n'est pas un gage
de stabilité car vous savez que ces deux
états sont déjà des états fiables de
population peut lire depuis au minimum
une centaine france c'est à dire celle
des opportunités mais l'epa seine pour
la région celui qui souffrira un petit
peu le plus intime outil qui souffre
d'une baisse des flux logistiques avec
l'ethiopie et surtout de son manque de
devises puisque l'économie éthiopienne
est quand même d'un très mauvais état
mais là cette situation je pense devrait
se stabiliser dans les prochains mois
mais si vous regardez bien le soudan le
soudan du sud l'erythrée la somalie
l'ethiopie se configure a pas de grandes
répercussions car ils ont tous déjà à un
niveau très élevé d'assistance ou de
perfusion par la communauté
internationale les nations unies mais
aussi la chine où l'union européenne
donc le mais le jeu de puissance
étrangère et par contres dangereux avec
au premier plan je dirais la turquie de
personnification par les ventes d'armes
notamment les drones qui ont fait
beaucoup de mal à cette armée tigréenne
et aux populations de tigres et l mais
c'est aussi les émirats arabes unis avec
leur implication avec ces trois pays
somalie erythrée ethiopie mais c'est
aussi en second plan pour régler leurs
comptes avec ses outils dont ils ont été
expulsés il ya une dizaine d'années
après avoir construit le port voyez donc
sept jeux de puissance étrangère et
taxes est dangereux quand même merci
beaucoup patrick ferrasse je rappelle
vous êtes docteur en géopolitique
président de l'association stratégie
africaine merci encore pour votre
analyse cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]